Hoje
[Aplausos]
eu tive um sonho tá ligado e meu sonho
era dar uma vida mais confortável a
minha família meu pai para minha mãe e
para o meu irmão e naturalmente
crescer fora daquela realidade ali da
Periferia que eu cresci no Guarujá
litoral de São Paulo e eu percebi esse
sonho através de uma coisa que eu
acreditava que é transformar a vida da
minha família das pessoas que eu amava
ter a música quando eu comecei a fazer
música aos 11 anos eu tinha uma
gravadora e essa gravadora eu era o
único artista Erro era o presidente eu
era uma iir hoje eu sei o nome de todas
as Essas funções mas na época não sabia
escrevi na porta do meu armário o nome
dessa gravadora e eu comecei a cantar
rap com 11 anos e umas batidas só que eu
achava que eu era tímido e para mim não
fazia muito sentido eu sei o artista
sendo que eu era tímido E aí eu comecei
a trabalhar com capinha de CD
fazendo compilação fazendo ali o a cópia
do CDs na minha quebrada né ah e tem uma
coisa que eu gostaria de falar aqui que
é sobre as renúncias né soubesse
escolhas que a gente tem que fazer toda
a escolha que a gente faz a gente
precisa decidir o que é que a gente vai
renunciar o que é que a gente vai abrir
mão e tem uma passagem muito importante
na minha vida e mudou a trajetória que
foi a perda da minha mãe quando a minha
mãe faleceu eu tinha 18 para 19 anos
minha mãe era professora de educação
infantil da Prefeitura do Guarujá e ela
deixou um recurso para mim que o meu
irmão
e esse recurso era um seguro de vida e o
fundo o fundo de garantia dela por ela
ter sido funcionária pública né No dia
do velório da minha mãe no dia do
enterro da minha mãe eu lembro como se
fosse hoje que as amigas dela falaram
seguinte para mim
e esse dinheiro que ela deixou para
vocês é engenheiro que ela trabalhou a
vida inteira para conquistar para
construir e agora ela se foi e ela tinha
um sonho Voltando a falar de sonhar ela
tinha um sonho qual que era o sonho dela
morar em frente à praia em Santos ali na
região do Gonzaga
Oi e aí as amigas dela para você de vir
percorrer atrás de cima da sua mãe aí eu
pensei caramba eu vou correr atrás desse
sonho dela
é só que
eu depois eu vou comprar o apartamento
não vou ter dinheiro para comprar o pa
pagar o condomínio Então para mim não
fazer muito sentido e era decidi correr
atrás do meu sonho e não do sonho da
minha mãe
comprar o meu apartamento com meu
dinheiro e aí meu irmão fizemos uma
escolha mais uma vez a escolha implica
em renúncia a gente renunciou o sonho da
nossa mãe de comprar o apartamento
visamos a escolha do investimento nos
nossos estudos eu vim para São Paulo
aqui na capital isso da computação
gráfica e cinema 3D e meu irmão montou
uma clínica odontológica no Guarujá que
tá indo super bem graças a Deus hoje eu
vivo de música
e hoje
eu consigo colaborar somar contribuir
com uma indústria com a periferia calça
vela com a cultura Urbana e viver do meu
sonho hoje eu continuo vivendo do meu
sonho mas eu preciso fazer uma mudança
de Rota eu precisei revisar a estrada
que eu trilhar para eu alcançar o meu
objetivo para alcançar o meu sonho que
era viver de música e dá uma vida
confortável para minha família eu achava
que ia ser cantando depois achava que ia
ser produzindo batidas e hoje eu sou
produtor fonográfico produtor
audiovisual e isso é tem que nem tiver
alguns resultados desse trabalho né Por
exemplo posso citar alguns aqui no nosso
canal é o maior canal do YouTube do
Brasil e da América Latina tem 65
milhões de inscritos É isso aí 65
milhões de inscritos não representa mais
ou menos um por cento da população
brasileira último número divulgado é que
o YouTube Tem 120 milhões de usuários
únicos aqui no nosso território Brasil o
nosso canal tem 123 milhões de usuários
únicos visitando consumir o conteúdo
dentro do nosso canal como que a gente
consegue ultrapassar esse número porque
aproximadamente 19 por cento da nossa
audiência vem de fora do Brasil é mais
uns trabalhos que a gente feio e aí
percorrendo entretenimento
entretenimento
de representatividade para a galera da
Periferia a gente fez uma série na
Netflix chamada sintonia sintonia foi a
Série Mais assistida da brasileira
dentro da plataforma em 2019
criada por mim de verme Quintela e
Felipe Braga e em 2020 nós ganhamos o
Grande Prêmio do cinema brasileiro como
melhor série de TV paga Tem muitas
pessoas me perguntam que foi que eu
aprendi nessa produção do sintonia né
porque moleque de favela construir esse
caminho o canal bom e depois criar uma
série para uma player de zeudi do mundo
o que foi que eu mais aprendi isso eu
aprendi que a gente
é conquista o que a gente insiste a
gente tem que persistir em cima das
coisas que a gente joga como prioridade
ali e dentro dessas coisas eu posso
citar alguns exemplos para mim era super
importante que se conectava muito com a
galera da minha quebrada usar o tênis
Mizuno Prophecy como o figurino ali
dentro
dessa série sendo que a equipe de
figurino como não tinham conhecimento
então assim sobre esse assunto de
Periferia sugeri O Jordan sugeri o
roupas de basquete que está muito
associada a cultura americana né quando
a gente estuda comunicação trabalho
comunicação da hora que a associação
Paulo a Nova York só que São Paulo é São
Paulo e Nova York Nova York são duas
coisas totalmente diferente então A
exemplo das coisas que eu tive que
persistir insiste ficar em cima disso ao
longo dos três anos e meio de processo
entre a ideia inicial de ir na casa do
Guilherme quintella e pensar nessa série
dia16 de Janeiro de 2016 a série até ser
veiculado sintonia dia nove de agosto de
2019 ou mais ou menos aí três anos e
meio durante as três anos eu tive que
identificar o que que era prioridade
para mim e ficar insistindo em todas as
etapas da produção e isso foi uma coisa
que eu aprendi não apenas abandonar e
cobrar no final eu fui acompanhando
aquele outro drogas para garantir que
aquilo que o gostaria que eu jogava com
prioridade EA tá com templado no final
do projeto mostra coisa que eu queria
falar também ao longo dessa dessa minha
história e da trajetória por muito tempo
eu fiquei pensando caramba eu acho que
eu não sou feliz O conta eu gostaria por
causa que eu ainda não conquistei tal
coisa Seja algum
eu já estou de desejo seja uma viagem
seja uma casa um carro e aí graças a
Deus os meus 28 anos eu consegui
alcançar a maioria ou quase todos esses
objetivos que eu estava perseguindo
desde os 11 anos que não trabalha com
música eu pensei caramba eu consegui
esses objetivos Mas eu continuo
esquecendo do principal
antes de ser seja feliz eu tava
esquecendo essas feliz tava procurando
você é tava procurando é trabalhar
com entretenimento entregar resultado e
sempre depositando a esperança da
felicidade na realização e execução a
entrega do próximo projeto hoje eu gosto
de falar para as pessoas que a gente tem
que ser feliz todos os dias sexta-feira
como sai do trabalho tem que ser feliz
mas tem que ser feliz mais segunda-feira
quando chega tem que ser feliz no sábado
no domingo na terça na quarta todos os
dias Muito obrigado pessoal é nós
estamos junto